se ai tanti ragazzi con il buon stefoni
rocket links dello show ma gino giugni e
lucas mico vai contro ciò marciano su no
giochi o quel palo gol madonna se usciva
questa prendevo il joystick lo usavo e
andavo a fare il pescivendolo rischio è
che sfiga che rimbalzo brutto momento
non stanno facendo nulla di pericoloso
telemarket il parco vado solo per caso
melo saltavo adesso me ne frega niente a
vado sul muro e la spazio
ecco questa traversa incredibile ma
certo ci sono o dio che pallonetto
uscito bellissimo berlino è perché è
bello ciò faccio coach un peccato non so
come prenderla io l'ho messa e donne che
come l'anno entrata questa palla lo
sapeva che sta sta cercando con noi
patty pravo ballo radici ricomponiamo un
secondo che stiamo prendendo mazzulata è
bravo bravo
no che quinci ha fatto buono
gliel'hanno turbo di niente no aiuto
come anziani non ha niente sta giocando
con il cuore della macchina nei muri
oddio grazie luca amico vai vai vai vai
che al momento tu ciocia c'è la pacata
che questo fatto è quello è un volto non
intanto si stanno pressando delle
prestito però ci sta il libero questa è
la parabili secondo me si è a pensavo
che pensavo in giro tutto talmente
diverso ma qui si chiamano gwadar you
doing stepsister ma che capita chieste
per il sensore lastra essere l'altro
socio evidenti
bravo papà che erano affatto un gol
incredibile continuato dal muro allora
pensa quello di cui parlavi e guarda
l'animazione del gol è pensa male pronto
pensava da giorgio pd siamo chiariti per
famiglia schizzi andiamo avanti ragazzi
mi dissocio terra bellissima e la palla
persa
eccola attenzione prova andare io con un
volo storto di latera un velo allora era
tutto calcolato
bello bello ciao ciao ciao show dai ma
credibile con le pinze e talmente lento
e però mi chiedevo di giusti non ci crea
l'olio veramente di socialità questa
partita l'azione ma la riguarda la
libera non ti fa scavalcare che se non
insegna loro
perfetto allora lo stesso così si gioca
porca vacca mancano 32 secondi e in 32
secondi possono vincere tutto anche il
campionato mondiale quindi occhio ok
tanto lui è lento ora ci mette 20
secondi se l'affare questa nona donna 6
scartato e aspetta aspetta aspetta mica
ti diro che schifo e tensione che
stamani ha finalità in musica prendiamo
gol è un casino mandanti morali
mi è capitato alle volte di prendere con
nell'ultimo secondo e poi prima di
supplementari prendere al calcio
nel calcio di nico grazie a due davanti
a due diamanti e un'attenzione
non è male e vogliamo stare io vorrei
salita diamante 3 vediamo se nella prof
non penso che sono a quella divisione
tra quindi radiato salire di una
divisione è ancora no non ancora
sono divisione iii fermo da quella di
prima
un'altra guida allora annate wired
scandinavia si chiama la città aspetta
che gli otto sognata sono i backstreet
boys della scandinavia propria
scandinavia che non è proprio una mi
dissocio
mi dissocio dal mio giocare che
effettivamente io non penso è
sottovalutato pampanga mese non pensavo
che non so per quanto ero andato proprio
6 da serie non potrà mai buttano dentro
una puntata dentista ringraziando
insacca ma dumbreck sai cosa devi
ringraziare deve ringraziare questo
glielo messo per omessa tagliano era di
petto la frase mela ha funzionato per ad
effetto si no punk funk ascoltami gol
allora non ne stiamo prendendo sede rai
che ti dico che va bene perché adesso
loro non solo perderanno ma perderanno
di rimonta che è peggio
quindi hai ragione ma sappi che ci
stanno insultando incerto e vai
tranquillo che barba conta vissuto
finale ok no porco demoni e torna è
arrivato pampa in cui frank e fango una
sega di partito fortissimo temi che
paiono però è veramente siamo stati
benedetti è questa non segnerà il
destino affidati bella bello però sono
esplosi entrambi allo stesso modo
abbiamo un sacco di tempo per recuperare
due gol anche panche però controllare ma
io ci sono
troppo forte si ok va bene turbo turbo
turbo o meno male un bravo bravissimo
no non riuscito di nuovo faccio finta
dovremmo preziosa toccata bene cacchio
sto aspettando in un suo errore
bravo tia perfetto l'ho tolto bravo
sono 10 i fan che ci prova ed
possiamo veramente spaccare tutti questi
no dai pasqua bella voglio banche bella
bel ali fratello come stai
bravo anche la mamma aspetta che ci
prova parte un cross uno turbo ma ci
provo lo stesso mamma perché lo stesso
né c'è bellissima diva 2 bellissima io
non lo turbano la teca bravissimo banche
paghino nevi giornata che farà po
sputato sullo schermo ma ne va a stare
dietro
l'ho saltato faro meno male che l'ho
visto arrivare al pan pan e sì perché
stava arrivando che l'ho detto avvenne
un rischio faccio festa bella da 02 42
bellissimo va in panne questa piazza è
certo e piange mamma mia che rimasta lì
bravo step non ti fa fregare niente 50
scopo c'era ancora di tutto vediamo il 5
vogliamo 55 che cross incredibile
madonna non me l'aspettavo mike dai vari
rimpalli
ma chi galla ma ecco che cos'è nasco
teca lascia togliere va bene va bene va
bene va bene va bene va bene lo vedo
distaccarci di fare perché quando mi è
stata io però pista ma anche parma 4 a 4
e il momento di andare in termini
dell'agenzia vai in parte
ok vai via via via credo che il tuo
ricordo uno me lo son saltarello però
c'è da altre canzoni pensava vecchio
bello
ok e tocca la maledetta non ha
preordinato punto che la bravissima
ancora una volta aspetta ci provo mamma
mia come diciamo l'appuntamento della
tocco non l'ha toccata a te l'ha avuto
io ok è proprio per lui cosa mezzo ma no
ragazzi non ci voglio credere
ok non ho turbo bello però ci posso
andare mai lasciato si sono incartati un
altro tocco
sì sì no no dai ragazzi di papa ci sono
ma l'aversa interna no ragazzi o ripeto
l'italia ti prego la mesata mano cosa ti
ha tolto senza turbo nono turno turbo
piangerlo respingere fila di papa no
[Musica]